some celebrities are out there getting
tested are you doing that have you
gotten tested for gonorrhea no not
gonorrhea wait
you're more worried right now about
gonorrhea than the gas okay okay it's
gotta be safe did did you even ask your
doctor if you needed to get tested
because I have a kidney transplant so I
just gave blood two weeks ago so dad
ever said you got it yeah okay so you're
in did you have gonorrhea god damn they
told you you have gonorrhea yes I need
this note and they said you've got three
crabs
wait you have three crabs and they gave
me the little cone with a little
ornament a little shampoo they don't
tell you you've got three crabs you've
either got crabs or you don't
what were they mo Larry and curly well
with a very name them so I'm gonna try
and sum up what we've learned here today
Tracy right okay you're advising
everybody to stock up on government
cheese and cocoa butter stay in their
Bugatti and sing the Sun will come out
tomorrow make sure you have at least 15
sharks in your aquarium in your home
it's the fourth largest in the world is
this about right absolutely and if
you've got an aunt with giant breasts
she should use one of her sixty-six
double D cups and put it over ten
children with some rubber bands yes and
you're telling pimps out there to be
safe and wear the masks right the trend
Bravo Yoko did
you've I don't know Tracy I don't know
what we accomplished here today I really
don't I don't know I don't know what we
accomplished you know we're here to
spread useful information
Tracy Europe completely out of touch
with reality you're spouting nothing
Tracy I don't know what I'm gonna do
with you I've been trying for years to
get you to talk saying keep loving you
everyone out there please stay safe all
my love to all the nurses the doctors
find this thing
I love you you're my heroes it's nice
you know what you spouted nothing but
craziness this whole time and then in
the end off with a beautiful message you
really did the last og very funny show I
think we have a clip here from Glasgow G
forgive me for disturbing your solitude
been a long time tre having things since
you got out I figured you didn't need me
anymore so did I but now I have so many
questions I need your wisdom but if your
quandary
I told myself when I got out to join I
was gonna be a forceful positive change
I want to get back to my community but
it seems like every time I take a step
forward I'll take three steps backwards
we're back
that was a good clip you like that yeah
you weren't even watching were you know
you filmed the last og is on TBS Tracy I
haven't laughed this hard in memory
you made me really happy thank you for
something's really wrong with you and
I'm happy because it makes it
I've never alive left this hard I love
you take care of yourself you're one of
the funniest human beings ever thank you
thank you letter card all right take
care bye